the Israeli Army is conducting an
extensive raid in Janine in the occupied
West Bank The Raid began over 24 hours
ago early on Tuesday seven people have
been killed including at least four in a
drone strike the Palestinian Health
Ministry said a 13-year-old is also
amongst the dead after Israeli forces
prevented an ambulance from getting to
him Charles statford joins us now from
rala so Charles bring us up to speed
with what the latest situation is now in
Janine
well we're just seeing video that's
dropped I suppose about half an hour ago
of what's being reported as the Israeli
military having surrounded a particular
home in the refugee camp in Janine um
they're on loud speakers and have been
um warning the occupants to to leave the
house immediately or uh face potentially
the house actually being destroyed um
they're also seem to be using what we
often call sound grenades um these are
these uh these shock explosive devices
that um can cause damage but are
incredibly loud um and are used to to to
scare protesters um um away from areas
we have seen over the last few hours
also arrested Palestinians blindfolded
having been LED or being led out of the
refugee camp this raid now is what we're
27 hours at least into it started at
3:00 a.m. yesterday morning
definitely one of the longest one of the
largest raids we've seen since the
beginning of the war involving dozens of
Israeli military vehicles and those
armored Israeli um army bulldozers that
cause so much destruction ripping up
infrastructure so so vital for people
living in these areas it's something
that the Palestinians and Palestinian
human rights groups often call uh
Collective punishment as you say uh
seven people killed so far in this raid
but important to recognize that one of
those people uh one of those persons was
was that 13-year-old boy who we are told
was actually had physical disabilities
and regularly went to the hospital to
receive treatment but on this instance
was prevented from getting into the
hospital because the Israeli military
had surrounded it all three hospitals um
and he passed away so still no sign that
this raid is over yet we're also hearing
reports that there have been raids in a
number of other areas across the
occupied West Bank over the course of
the last few hours a raid on heon we
understand according to sources that at
least five people arrested in that raid
three people also arrested in a raid on
B laham which The Wider world knows as
Bethlehem and within the last hour or so
um we could hear again what sounded like
those sound bombs those sound grenades
being used and we're now hearing that at
least one person has been arrested here
in rala okay Charles traford bringing us
the very latest there from across the
occupied West Bank thanks very much
Charles